joining me today is the founder for act
for america
a new york times best-selling author and
author of the new book rise
in defense of judeo-christian values and
freedom
bridget gabriel welcome back to the
reuben report thank you dave i'm
delighted to be back with you
i am delighted that you're here first
off before we do anything else i was
going to wear the exact same shirt
i love this shirt it's a girly girly
shirt that is a girly girly shirt i love
what's going on here okay
so i had you on about maybe a year and a
half ago or so
you are the only person in the history
of the reuben report
that you caused a tear to formulate in
my eye i think you know
exactly when it happened yeah so before
i even let you say anything
we're throwing to the clip we only
take care of freedom and preserve it to
the next generation
and i am doing my part as an american as
a brave american
in the home of the brave to make sure i
follow in the footsteps of our founding
fathers
and do my part as they entrusted me
with that which they have created i feel
it is my duty
to make sure to preserve it to pass it
to my children and
their american children and many
generations to come
that's why we fight and i am so
fortunate that
through this fight and it is a fight for
freedom for liberty for democracy for
security
for human rights i am privileged to meet
the most
amazing people that i would never
otherwise meet like
sitting here with you today and meet
friends that have become
lifelong friends literally like family
to me that i would never have otherwise
met if it wasn't doing for what i do
so do i get depressed doing what i do
talking about terrorism and national
security of course i do
i'm human like everybody sometimes i cry
sometimes i'm completely depressed over
things that are happening
sometimes i hurt deeply by people who
stab me in the back or say bad things
about me or even reading my wikipedia
profile
but what keeps me so energized is the
american people and the american spirit
knowing that we
are making a difference we are growing
we are changing our country
we are fighting we have a purpose so
when you and i die on our deathbed we
can look back and we can say
i made a difference as we take our last
breath
and that's enough for me that is how you
end an interview i mean that's
it right there that was that was like
your opus right there
well because i spoke from the heart and
when you speak from the heart
your message resonates with people and
this is exactly why people like you
and me are having such traction with a
lot of people who are saying
we love what you're saying it's about
time that somebody will say the things
that you are saying
our message is resonating and you know
why people want something genuine and
they can tell you know
i always tell my children the one thing
you can never fake
love you can never fake love people
people can tell when you're genuine
and in a world that we live in today
where everything is fake
everything is about social media and how
things appear before the camera and
and and what's in it for me and i'm
gonna be your friend because i'm gonna
get something out of it
when people like you and i put our life
on the line because
of the conviction that we have about the
truth that we are speaking
and why we are willing to go to great
extent to just
fight for that truth it resonates with
people
so i couldn't wait to be with you today
this is great what a team
no i'm thrilled you're back were you did
you always have this kind of passion i
mean when you were on last time we told
or you told your your whole life story
which is absolutely fascinating if you
want to give me just like a a two minute
recap and we'll link to it down below so
people can watch the whole thing if they
haven't so if you want to give me a
little recap on that
but i also want to know where you're
that that smile that joy that presence
where does that come from within you and
did you always have that
i love life and i am
so passionate about life is because i
lived from the age of 10 till the age of
20 waiting to die
every single day so every single day in
my formulative years
when i opened my eyes and i saw sunshine
outside
i didn't know if i'm gonna live to see
the sunset
so living in a bomb shelter you know
people ask me where this question comes
from
my 911 happened to me in 1975 when
radical islamists blew up my
home bringing it down bearing me under
the rubble wounded
i ended up in a hospital for two and a
half months and later when i came back
home
my home was no longer the home i left i
ended up living in this bomb shelter
eight by ten room underground
no electricity no water and very little
food
and that's where i lived for seven years
of my life
robbed of my youth barely interacting
with people
barely interacting with people my age i
lived with my parents who were an
elderly couple in that bomb shelter
so all this uh a couped up passion
now i tell people i'm making up for last
time so
i love life i'm so grateful for life i'm
so grateful for
the people i meet the places i go i
never thought i'd live the day beyond 20
and then i never thought i'd leave a day
beyond 30. and here i am
living life i just turned 54 years old
i'm so proud
to make it summer thank you thank you
when
when you have survived as long as i have
survived
you brag about i made it to this day
at this age so this is why i love life
so we're going to link to your
our original sit down and your whole
story about growing up in lebanon and
all that so people can watch that if
they haven't seen it
um but not everybody likes you and i
remember
before i had you on the first time uh
you know when people
google you and you even reference this
in in that clip we're talking about you
know if you check your wikipedia thing
people say all sorts of awful things
about you and all this and i was a
little worried i was like ah
it's like i'm gonna have brigitte on and
i'm gonna get hate for it and all that
now i'm really past that part of life
now i just want to do what i think is
right and i want to sit down with
with people like you and have those
conversations um but are you
shocked at the kind of pushback you get
for defending
the west and defending judeo-christian
values
i am no longer shocked i was in the
beginning i was very hurt
very disappointed i thought my message
of course the west is going to resonate
it's going to resonate and the west
people are going to appreciate
why it's important to fight for freedom
of speech i was born and raised in
lebanon
in a country where if you stand up
against the status quo and you speak
against the regime
you are killed they come take you in the
middle of the night kill you you'll
disappear you'll
they'll never hear from you again i
still have friends who disappeared 30
years ago their parents don't even know
if they are alive or dead
journalists in my country of birth in
lebanon get killed for writing the wrong
thing
so when i came to the west and when i
started speaking in defense of
our freedoms and our values and our way
of life and the american values
of of you know standing up for the truth
and speaking the truth without having to
be
worried about somebody killing you i
could not believe
people will will come against me like
that but you know what
if you don't stand for something you
know
you have to stand up for what you
believe those are the people that make a
difference and usually people that make
a difference in this world are not
popular
the most hated people in the world look
at churchill i mean you know when he was
alive
you know people hated him they thought
oh my gosh you know
look at him today people people quote
people
that have spoken such words of wisdom
but people laughed at them when they
were saying them
and so here we are today we stand up and
we fight and
it doesn't matter what people say about
me i do what i believe is right because
i believe
we are on a mission to save western
civilization which is under attack
right now and i'm willing to do my part
to make it happen
is part of the problem of the west now
is that we don't
have enough stories like yours because
we've had it pretty good
in the west for the last you know 50
some odd years certainly in the united
states we've got it pretty good here
so we've sort of gotten fat and lazy on
freedom we don't know what we're
fighting for we don't know
what our the generations before us lived
through you
lived through something so then you come
here and then you see all these people
that are slowly eroding their freedoms
and you're like whoa
i know what this is where this leads
exactly my past
is america's future unless america wakes
up today
see i am the anne frank who lived to
tell about it
can you imagine if anne frank was alive
and the nazis
were spreading worldwide and she just
escaped the concentration camps and she
came to the united states
and nazism started rising in the united
states she would be saying the same
words that she said when she was alive
and
with in my case i started speaking after
the attacks on 9 11 on the united states
i started speaking about the threat
of radical islam to world peace and our
national security
but because americans had it so easy
they cannot fathom that some people
could hate us so much
even though radical islamic terrorists
hijacked airplanes and used them as
human missiles flying them into
skyscrapers with the intention of
killing
not 3 000 but maybe 50 000
that worked in that building you know if
they were late only 15 minutes
they would have killed tens of thousands
of americans um
and so this is what i was talking about
but americans are such good people
people in the west who have never
experienced
the type of terrorism that i lived under
cannot relate and think that somebody
could be that bad that actually that's
their real intention
uh to kill as many people as possible so
how do you wake people up to that then
because it's a really hard because not
everyone can have the lived experience
that you've had
you don't have to wake all the people up
you just have to wake
some of the people up you just have to
wake up the passionate
i you know in my book rise i say two
percent of the passionate will
always rule the 98 percent indifferent
it doesn't take money to change the
world two percent of the passionate
will always rule the 98 percent
indifferent you just need to get people
who are
fired up for your cause you need to get
people who actually
understand the problem and get the
problem and want to do something to
change the world
those are the people you need to rally
around you those are the people who are
going to make a difference in this world
and those are the people that i that i
try to communicate with and because of
that
i was able to build an organization act
for america
i'm proud to tell you that we are now
over 1 million
members 1 million it's incredible we
have chapters nationwide
we have passed bills 100 bills
on the federal level as well as the
state level to protect america
so when people tell me don't you worry
about the names i mean people call you
names you know they they they
they make you look bad they're on a list
the slpc
splc calls me a white supremacist
how do you like how do you like those
white supremacist lips and
white supremacist skin and and this
white supremacist hair
um but i tell people when people slap
labels on you it's because they cannot
argue with your facts
that's why the only thing they can do is
call you names they cannot debate you on
the facts
and you know i tell people all the time
don't worry about the labels and don't
worry about the haters
the new york times in my last book they
must be stopped
the book came out in september of 2008
the new york times interviewed me
and they couldn't find one quote
in my article so what did they do they
titled the article
radical islamophobe not just an
islamophobe i
am a radical islamophobe can you imagine
if i would have let that
stop me because i was hurt that somebody
didn't like me and they could be a
radical islamophobe
instead of hiding under a table you know
trying to kind of
pat my emotions i went there and
continued doing exactly what i do best
since 2008 till today my organization
has helped pass
100 bills and that's why i tell people
don't let the naysayers and those who
slap labels on you stop you
keep on moving forward what do you make
of these leftist organizations whether
it's
splc or the adl or now in the media the
new york times
that are actually empowering the very
ideologies that would love to take away
all of their freedoms and in this way i
mean it's you've got this sort of
you've got the progressives basically in
bed with the islamists
and to me it's like they're just sort of
willful idiots or
there's probably some other pejoratives
i could use exactly you know and my book
cries i have a whole chapter titled the
leftist islamist coalition
because that's exactly what we are
seeing right now coming together the
enemy of my enemy is my friend so we are
seeing two people that do not agree
in it with anything that we say do not
believe in america's exceptionalism
do not believe that america should have
strong borders do not believe that we
know that we need to have a national
identity we need
i mean securing our border meaning
securing protecting our national
identity
they do not believe in borders they do
not believe in language they want to
bring america down to the
on par to the rest of the world you know
america is equal with venezuela
no one is better than anybody all
societies are created equal
you and i that even though people are
created equal in the eyes of god
societies are not created equal and so
what we are seeing right now is leftist
organizations working with the islamists
so you've got
organizations like the aclu the southern
poverty law center
planned parenthood uh moveon.org working
with people like linda sarsour
who is a devout islamist a proponent of
sharia law
and working with people like her or with
care council and american islamic
relations
the aclu is basically the legal arm of
care the council on american islamic
relations
so do you think they realize what's
going on here this is the part that i'm
always
sort of because i don't like impugning
people's motives right
so it's like do they realize that
they're working with people
who once they have the power will gladly
cut them out
right no they don't yeah they just don't
they don't because people that work for
the aclu
people that work for uh uh
different leftist organizations have
good hearts
they love america and they cannot
believe that people
could be bad or people could use them
for their end goal
you know when i talk about the muslim
brotherhood project and you and i have
talked about the muslim brotherhood
project in our previous
interview people need to go watch that
interview
everybody watching us right now they
need to go back and watch that previous
interview
um the muslim brotherhood wrote a plan a
100 year plan for radical islam to
infiltrate and dominate the west
and establish an islamic government on
earth what
makes the plan so unique especially the
plan for the united states for the
destruction of america
the last page of the plan for america
lists 29
front islamic organizations set up in
the united states
with the specific purpose of sabotaging
america and destroying it from within
many of these organizations that i
mentioned islamic society of north
america
the msa muslim student association care
which started as
iap islamic association for palestine
leiru became care because they wanted to
create another name because the fbi was
on their tail knowing that they are a
hamas front
in the united states those are the names
mentioned
so what we're seeing right now is people
like the aclu
moveon.org the southern poverty law
center are basically used as the useful
idiots at the hands of an islamist with
an agenda
so while i am very upset at
how the adl or the splc
or the aclu is taking the side of
islamist
against people like me i'm not sure what
they say about you but i know they hate
my guts
yeah and so i see that and it's
it's sad to realize that their good
intentions are being used to do
something bad at the end
but they don't realize it at this point
meanwhile they're working with the
islamists
against people like me who basically are
trying to warn
against the same people who are going to
destroy them at the end and that's why i
framed the question that way because i
don't like attacking people's motives
and i believe that if we were to sit
down with all of the people at the aclu
that
the vast majority of them are are
totally doing
all of these things for what they
believe to be the right reasons the
right three
and yet they've been just sort of
tricked into having some really unholy
alliance well look the southern poverty
law center
uh the same thing they started as a good
organization fighting the klu klux klan
doing something good
that was a result that they raised money
they fought the ku klux klan and look
the the klu klux klan deserves to be in
a hall because we in america will never
ever tolerate
such true hatred but for them right now
to slap the label hate on
anybody who speaks the truth or do not
agree with their point of view
they don't know what my heart is see i
never judge anybody's heart i am the
same way
you never know people would ask me about
uh barack obama do you think he's a
muslim
you know i cannot judge anybody's heart
i don't know who he prays for i don't
know what's between him and he's god
it's between him and his god that's what
he does in the privacy of his own home
and i will never judge where he stands
and a lot of people on the right didn't
even like me saying those words
but that's the truth i will never judge
what's in somebody's heart or what's in
somebody's mind
i judge them by their actions so now
when people slap labels on me oh she's a
hater
you don't even know me you have never
even sat down with me and talked with me
how can you slap a label an emotional
label on somebody that you don't even
know
if you're a hater you're a seriously
much better actress than hater because
you got me fooled lady i i'm telling you
i mean you know it is so
sad to see that coming from them and
they're not listening
to whatever explanation or even when we
reach out to them they don't want to
talk to us they don't want to hear our
side of the view
it's like they judged us in absentia and
that is it
you know speaking of judging in absentia
they are no better than the terrorists
in lebanon
you know i went to israel this year and
visited my parents grave i don't know if
you know my parents are buried with
oscar
schindler and mount zion yeah and so
this was the quickly
tell people how you ended up in israel
after leaving lebanon
well i left lebanon i ended up moving to
israel becoming a news anchor for world
news and working in jerusalem
and when my parents died i wanted to
make sure
that i buried them in israel because i
wanted to make sure that my children yet
unborn
will always know where my loyalty lies
and
because i'm a firm believer that actions
speak louder than words
so i wanted to make sure i honor my
parents because
i adore my parents this is a very
sensitive subject with me
i'm an only child i worship my parents
i live every single day of my life doing
everything i do to honor them and their
legacy
and you know speaking of hatred some
former employer did me wrong when i was
22 years old and i remember sitting on
my father's lap in his wheelchair
hugging him i was crying and i said oh
daddy i just hate them i can't believe
they did this to us
and my father said to me he said i never
ever want to hear that word
coming out of your mouth i never raised
you to hate
and for nothing else because of the way
i adore my father
at that day at 22 years old i vowed i
will never hate somebody my father died
like two weeks later i will never ever
allow hate to enter my heart towards my
enemies towards anybody
i don't hate anybody so when my parents
died i burned them
in in jerusalem they are buried with
oscar schindler and mount zion
where actually later he was brought in
and buried next to them
so this year i went back to lebanon to
israel and because i cannot go to
lebanon hezbollah wants me dead
so i go to israel i visit israel i meet
with the idf i actually
was the first lebanese person to ever
make it to the rooftop of the idf
headquarters in tel aviv
and i recorded videos with the
spokesperson of the idf and with the top
generals
we recorded videos to be broadcast to
the united nations to the international
community
video to be broadcast to lebanon about
how why we
need to work together towards peace why
we need to love each other
put hate aside forget what you're told
about the jews israel doesn't want
anything but peace with its neighbors
let's work together on peace
and for that allah aired that on
lebanese television
they charged me with treason now i am
wanted dead in lebanon
and sentenced to death by hanging an
absentee
so here we have a group of terrorists in
my home country of lebanon
who judged me and who i am and i deserve
to be
sentenced to death by hanging because
they did not agree
with me preaching a message of love
about being friends with the jews
so here we have them calling me haters
yeah and yet i have the leftist in
america the southern poverty law center
and these people
calling me haters simply because i'm
warning about the islamic
terrorist threat all right well you've
got too much good in you to focus on the
haters but i do have one other question
about the haters and then we're going to
just put it behind us which is when
majinwa has sued the southern poverty
law center now he's been removed from
their anti-muslim
extremist list and you are on there
still as far as i know
uh is ion still on there actually
that lit yeah i understa over there you
know me and ayan of course are you
kidding
um linda sarsour wants your
yeah once my private parts removed miss
women's feminist movement you know um
but the world is turned upside down so
we are still on that list
um did you consider a lawsuit or
anything because i'm not generally for
lawsuits in these cases but it magic
proved that
if they've really wronged you and you
can get the backing to get the lawyers
to do it
that ultimately justice does prevail
we talk to our attorneys to sue them and
it's going to cost a lot of money and
they can drag it for years and years and
years they've got 90
90 attorneys on staff well we have to
depend on the generosity of attorneys to
do with pro bono
they can track it forever plus because
i'm a public person and the head of an
organization
that will get us into discovery which
means they not only
can't subpoena me which i don't say
anything bad i'm not worried
but they can go after my chapters and
any communications our chapters have
done with their friends
now our chapters are completely
independent their members are completely
independent
i don't even know who they are so if
somebody sent a personal email
to a third party mentioning any word
about hate which we are completely not
responsible for because
they don't speak about headquarters they
can say see we told you they've got
people that hate
and so because i do not know three four
levels down see
najib doesn't have a national
organization
definitely not with chapters and members
the way we do so he's only responsible
for what he says
i can fight and defend what i say
but i cannot fight and defend what
people do i don't even know
look the splc went after us and they
said oh we've got white supremacists you
know who show up to our rallies
we had rallies on the side street corner
anybody
can stand on the side street corner you
know you cannot say that these members
belong to my organization
yeah but they do and that's the tactic
of the left right now
all right let's focus on the book so the
the subtitle is in defense of
judeo-christian values and freedom
so just most simply if someone said to
you what are
judeo-christian values what are they
what are the most fundamental
judeo-christian values that we need to
know
well judeo-christian values are
the bedrock of western civilization they
are the foundation
of what we have today in america and
this is not a religious book at all you
read it you endorsed it
it's not a religious book i got a little
bird in there what you got a little
blurb in there
what are the most fundamental freedoms
i'll give you a perfect example freedom
of speech
people don't realize where that freedom
comes from you know
in israel the hasidic jews they debate
the bible they 24 hours a day that's all
they do
they debate the bible and where does
that come from the bible says come let's
reason together
means let's debate ideas i may not like
your idea you may not like mine
and we can have five other people who
make look at the same verse completely
differently
but the reason why we debate ideas is
because we can learn
from each other and better understand
what statements mean
where the author who wrote that
statement meant by it
we all know that god didn't write the
bible people wrote the bible
so part of our fundamental way of
thinking
the freedom of speech the ability to
come together and debate ideas
and passionately debate these ideas yet
agreed to respectfully disagree and walk
away
people don't realize that comes from the
foundation of judeo-christian
foundation you know even people who are
not religious
understand that's so uniquely western
you know they don't do that in in in the
islamic world for example
you don't debate ideas why because in
the quran
the quran was written it's the word of
god it's not debatable it's not
negotiable you cannot look back you
cannot change verses
you don't even talk about it you can't
even question it very different than the
way we are
so when i write in the book about and i
actually i have a chapter titled
uh the death of free speech where i talk
about how we are
losing our ability to speak the truth
because then you're labeled you're bigot
people are afraid am i going to be
you know blackmailed am i going to be
boycotted am i going to lose my job
um and so it's we're silencing ourselves
and that's why i titled the book rise
rise
in defense of judeo-christian values and
freedom because we're losing those
freedoms
those american values before our very
eyes are you watching this chip away
more in europe than in the united states
right now for all our problems around
this and i agree
the bigger problem right now is that
we're silencing ourselves rather than
the government coming to
silence us although that could
potentially be a problem in the future i
don't sense it's a huge problem right
now
europe has a whole other set of problems
around free speech do you think that
they're
more suited to lose faster because they
don't have
a first amendment the way we do oh yeah
they are far more advanced than losing
their rights and their freedoms than we
are
and they did it by self-censorship you
know i landed in london i was speaking
in london in 2007
so i land in london i'm standing there
waiting for my luggage with the
um pilot and the hostesses
uh we were in a private section and they
said oh what are you doing here and i
said oh i'm just here for like three
days i'm giving a speech
in parliament i was speaking to the uh
british parliament
and they said oh what are you going to
be talking about and i said the threat
of radical islam to world peace and
national security
and all of a sudden silence for 30
seconds you could hear a pin drop
they didn't know how to react or what to
say they were so
afraid to react unless somebody hears
something the taxi driver
my driver picked me up to drive me to my
hotel and we were talking in the car and
i told him
he asked me again what are you doing
here and i said the same thing he said
brigitte
in 10 years i believe we're going to
have blood on the streets of london by
radical islamists
we are at war and it didn't even take
ten years within five years we already
started seeing stabbing
on the streets of london and stuff like
that so in europe they are afraid to
talk about it and they do not have
the freedom of speech that we have and
that's why it is so important
to defend the freedom of speech that we
have and god bless them our founding
fathers with their wisdom they knew
exactly what they were doing i mean look
remember they came from europe
so when they wrote us what they gave us
the constitution and our bill of rights
and all of that stuff they knew exactly
why they put some of these amendments in
there
so all right so let's just put europe
aside since we're in the united states
they're gonna have to deal with that
we'll deal with it here
um okay we can get people to rise but
what else do we have to do to have a
discussion about this
that's going to stop the people that are
going to use all of those labels so i
know even in the book you make a point
of saying of course
this is not all muslims and don't be
bigoted towards muslim people
we're talking about an ideology a lot of
people have been doing that for the last
couple years tried to separate people
from ideas and all that and still get
all the labels thrown at them
what are some of the other techniques we
can use to talk about these things and
and not be crushed by by all the labels
don't waste your breath
because there is nothing you can say at
this point
no matter what you say the enemy the
svlc
the adl moveon.org organizing for action
all the progressive organizations
they're not willing to listen to you
they don't want to listen to you
look we organized march against sharia
march for human rights
last year a year and a half ago uh and
we had
rallies in 29 cities in 21 states and we
timed it with the pulse nightclub
bombing in florida
because it was june 10th we wanted to
shine a light about the
hatred of this ideology against gays
what they do to gays i mean look at the
pulse nightclub bombing the
the people that organized our rallies in
new york it was organized and headed by
two gay guys
the rally in atlanta was headed by a
muslim man though we had an imam
speaking in seattle we had miriam
ibrahim the sudanese survivor speak at
our rally
in virginia beach as well as the iranian
muslim leader
of the iranian movement you know to to
to move away from the mullahs yeah
do you think any of the media covered
any of that all they did is show up on
the street corner say no hate say no to
hate say no to hate
they didn't even bother yeah understand
what we were doing
so don't waste your breath right now
people tell me why are you speaking to
the choir bridget we need to talk to
other people
at this time you need to mobilize the
choir because when you need
your house cleaned it is the choir that
shows up it is the choir that brings you
food when you're sick
it is the choir that mops the church or
the temple when it needs cleaning it's
the choir that brings the flowers
and that's all that matters to keep your
house up and keep it protected
and that's why right now don't waste
your breath on the labels
make sure you fight make sure you lobby
your elected officials make sure you
understand the power of the gavel
why it is important to call your elected
officials you know in my book
what makes this book so unique is at the
end of every chapter
i have a section titled rise up and act
where i give people ideas so i want to
do all that at the end i want all your i
want all of your absolute advice on this
but but you hit on something that i
think is really interesting there how
there's a connection to all of this and
the way the media reports
yeah you're right that when they cover
your events or when they cover a lot of
the
the people that i'm friends with that i
have on the show whatever they say
it's like they only focus on the haters
they only focus on that the one little
outsider that's that's doing something
that's bad and not on all the good
how how do you think this happened to
the media or is there a way that it can
be fixed or does it need to burn to the
ground or what
because the progressive media is not
interested in dialogue they are
interested
in winning see we on the conservative
side
you know and it's such a shame i never
thought of myself as a conservative
i mean i don't know if i told you i
voted for al gore i was a proud democrat
you know i'm a 911 you know conservative
as they call as conservative
uh but this is where we are in our
nation right now they consider people
like you conservative
because you speak about you know
important issues that are now known as
oh that's what the conservatives talk
about yeah
you know so what we are seeing right now
is the media is interested in winning
while we are interested in having a
dialogue how can we get through to them
how can we speak with them you know and
find a bridge where we can talk to them
about that they're not interested in
talking to us
they're interested in silencing our
voices and the sooner we know that
the better we are in fighting our battle
and learning how to win our battle
and you add to that funders like soros
you know in my book i have a whole
section about soros and him funding the
media
soros right now has spent doesn't that
make you an anti-semite if you talk
about soros that's their new meme
i didn't even know he was jewish until
about a year ago
right and everything that he does is
usually against israel
exactly the height of stupidity uh
i mean you know you would think he
sounds and talks like an anti-semite
much more than me remember he is the one
who worked with the doctors with the
nazis
on on um and actually had a smile when
people asked him
how did you feel about going in and
working with the nazis against your own
people he said well
you know somebody had to do it so i know
i didn't see any problem with it
you know yeah you're not making that up
by the way no no i mean i watched this
interview because i was very interested
on
what makes this man the way he is i
study my enemies
i spend a lot of hours actually studying
my enemies
to understand how they think why why do
they behave you know trying to pick up
on cues
so you look at somebody like george
soros who is
interested in transforming america into
his vision of how the world should be
and he has the billions and he's willing
to spend it 43 billion has already been
spent on the media
on soros funded media entities from
since 2002 and so when you look today at
sources tentacles that extend to 33
media outlets including abc nbc cbs
msnbc
the washington post the associated press
which i detail in my book
uh even the the to give you an example
which i talked in the book
columbia school of journalism gave them
600 000
to their journalism school because he
wanted to impact the reporting on how
reporters report on the media issues in
the future
so nobody was paying attention to this
stuff but this is exactly how we end up
with reporters
who are no longer reporters they are
activists with a national platform
media platform who get on television
every night and basically
spew the same talking political points
approved by soros
and they all say the same thing whether
it's the huffington post the new york
times though associated press
reuters msnbc cnbc abc
the same buzzword and it's all
coordinated how concerned are you that
on the social media front where people
like you have been able to make gains
you know i'll see every now and again
you'll talk about oh i just suddenly
lost 5 000 followers on twitter or
something like that
that we're fighting a losing battle on
that front ultimately because
these companies a i think there are a
lot of political connections and who
knows what's going on behind the scenes
but b
they've basically embraced the the
leftist ideology and
they're not really around to make sure
that bridget gabriel's voice can be
heard
well we lose followers by the tens of
thousands tens of thousands
uh and we are seeing that happen
especially now at a dramatic pace
uh but you continue on doing what you
are doing
there is nothing you can do to change it
uh you just continue pushing
we are working with members of congress
to make sure that there is fairness
in reporting and that the government
will intervene to make sure
uh that we don't have a monopoly look
they did the same thing with microsoft
remember microsoft had a monopoly
the government had to intervene and they
said no you cannot stop anybody else who
wants to develop computers
apple didn't have a chance if the
government didn't intervene with
microsoft
so we know that there is precedent but
here is the secret this is
my libertarian brain all the bells go
off on that stuff though because i
don't want the government to do it it's
like for me it's like the last resort
even though i know that this is
obviously a very personal issue to me as
someone that puts this up on youtube and
the rest of it
we want fairness we're not telling them
silence anybody
but we are saying to them allow people
to speak their mind
you know if i own the media platform and
i do not agree with you
at all in what you say as an american
i will bite my tongue and grit my teeth
and listen to what i absolutely
passionately oppose i'm not saying you
but anybody you know you could be saying
you know
whoever but i will fight for your right
to do it i will not silence you because
it is
unamerican to silence you so as
americans
we owe it to each other at least to
defend these rights so we can pr
so we can pass them on to our future
generations you
never really own freedom david we only
preserve it for the future generation
and i said that statement with you
before
and i actually have it going all
throughout my book
these are the rights that our founding
fathers gave
everything and most of them died broke
to give us these rights that we have
today
the least we can do is preserve it for
the next generation that's all we're
asking for
but you know the secret to success
regardless of how much the
the social media puts you on facebook
jail or twitter banshee or shadow venue
etc
tenacity tenacity tenacity you keep on
pushing you keep on pushing you keep on
pushing
and you never ever ever give up
that is the secret to success
you